this is for Ned and I apologize in
advance for your ears I'm not a singer
oh I like it already walking down the
street I'm hoping to run into you and I
do but you've killed yourself
this is embarrassing when people
describing they'll often just saved it
but to me you'll always be stangard and
calm on it nine-one-one what's your
emergency
I'm a college we need an ambulance with
no girlfriend
oh my voice if you had enough challenge
will I still feel the same just sounds
like me something my name is Billy
Browns my hair is long no no honey
blonde what do I keep describing my hair
so much he'll never forget I don't know
me once about really heaven you know
what makes me laugh Billy you're exactly
like Ned I'm not him unless you have his
faith his Blastoise his hair and a job
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
dang garden come my little name I
believe thank you do that don't clap for
her why a man died and she's just up
there like Oh song i dink row head and
you're both wearing denim jackets to a
memorial and you're all clapping away
clapping oh it was really just a coffee
guy clap a living mr. bigshot head of
the department BFS you know what to
Spira me no don't fire her I'm not gonna
fire I can't fire someone for doing a
bad Popeye imitation in a dead man's
office mediocre and how did you become
friends with my boss that's Francis
right I just totally reminds him that
what you just said
um I am my own person okay and this is
whack all right y'all havin a whack okay
I need you to have some rough left okay
we all gonna die and resurrect I think
all the day is okay I'm sorry I have a
thing with funerals okay agent you're
having problem is leaving I'm normal
I can't be normal no one says I'm normal
someone get my Yamaha
zoo case up a TV that's why you don't
see but but they still wanna be